for 146 years the Barnum & Bailey Circus
was known for being the greatest show on
earth none of it would have been
possible if it were not for an ambitious
entrepreneur who was named PT Barnum
while his life in Korea were sometimes
the source of controversy he truly was
brilliant businessman and many of his
ideas forever changed the entertainment
industry as we know it today
[Music]
Phineas Taylor Barnum was born in 1810
in Bethel Connecticut his parents filo
Barnum and Irene Taylor were farmers he
rented out rooms in their home for a bit
of extra income his grandfather was a
well-respected judge in the town on the
day of his baptism PT Barnum inherited a
4.6 acre piece of lands from his
grandfather called ivy island his
parents they were poor but as a child he
grew up believing that he was the
richest kid in town because he thought
that he had inherited a private island
somewhere where he could build a house
someday when he was 10 years old his
parents finally took him on a trip to
visit ivy islands where he discovered
that it was virtually worthless the
island was simply muddy land in the
middle of a swamp and it was filled with
poisonous snakes ticks and poison ivy he
never did anything with that land today
it's now part of the Nature Reserve
called the Bethel land trust this was
clearly disappointing to young Barnum
and it left him yearning for a reality
where he truly would be rich enough to
buy a private island but he wasn't
interested in the traditional ways of
making money by his own admission he had
the reputation of being the laziest boy
in town because he hated doing farm work
and any sort of manual labor instead of
forcing Phineas into caring for the
family farm his father helped him get a
job as a clerk in the town grocery store
this was a perfect fit and Phineas grew
to love the idea of running his own
business when he was only 15 years old
his father died and he was now the man
of the family this motivated him even
more to make as much money as he
possibly could he
possessed by the entrepreneurial spirit
and he began trying different business
ventures right away his most successful
business as a teenager was running a
lottery while working in the grocery
store he had an endless supply of glass
bottles and tin advertising trays that
he was expected to simply throw away he
knew that these items would be useful in
people's homes and he wanted to recycle
them in some way but people they were
not interested in buying these things
secondhand he started selling tickets
for a lottery instead he promised that
half of the tickets sold would be
guaranteed to win something there were a
few big cash prizes and also the
consolation prizes were the items that
he got the free
he sold a thousand tickets in the first
week and he continued to run the lottery
over and over again when he was just 16
years old he used all the money he
earned from these lotteries to move to
Brooklyn New York to open his own
grocery store unfortunately though he
caught smallpox and had to move back to
Connecticut so his mother could help
nurse him back to health after
recovering from his illness he knew he
needed to try again when he was 18 he
opens up a confectionary store in his
hometown that sold fruit and candy he
was able to run more lotteries from this
store he married his first wife charity
Hallett when he was 19 years old and she
was 21 they would eventually go on to
have four daughters together well he
never really was overly romantic he did
write that his wife was a treasure and
that without charity I am nothing and he
was 21 he wrote several passionate
articles about politics and send them
into the local newspaper but they were
all rejected he decided that if no one
was going to publish his work he was
self-publish his own paper pools
The Herald freedom he had enough money
to buy his own printing press and he
handed out the newspapers in town
in one of his articles he exposed the
corrupt leaders of the town's local
church and then sued him for libel and
since he had no proof to back up his
claims in court he ended up paying a
$100 fine and spent 60 days in jail when
he was released he became a local hero
and a leader of the liberal movement
everyone loved him in Bridgeport but he
decided that he achieved all he could
possibly achieve in Connecticut he
wanted to move to New York City where he
knew he
would have many more opportunities to
earn a fortune PT and charity Barnum
bought a boarding house in New York City
so that they could earn some income by
renting out their extra rooms just like
his parents had done back in Connecticut
he used his knowledge from working in
retail to have partial ownership of a
grocery store without having to do any
of the work and he continued to run his
weekly lotteries he had set himself up
in a pretty great financial situation
and he was still only in his early 20s
his family's basic needs of food and
housing were met but his sights were on
bigger and better ways to make as much
money as he possibly could when he was
25 years old he met a man who told him
about Joice Heth who was an elderly
african-american slave woman she claimed
to be George Washington's nanny and
would go on and on with her stories of
their time together if this was true it
would make her 161 years old Barnum was
able to pay her owner $1,000 in order to
put her on display she looked so
incredibly old that people actually
believed that she may truly have been
161 people came from all over New York
City to see her she died after only one
year of touring there was a public
autopsy that revealed she was only about
80 years old but people were not angry
about the deception while it was they
Homburg people they still enjoyed the
spectacle this gave PT Barnum a preview
of the showman experience if he could
find even more fantastic and interesting
attractions he didn't have to do any of
the hard manual labor that he dreaded so
much he could just hire talented people
to perform and collect the money from
ticket sales PT Barnum tried to sell
tickets to acts with performers who
specialized in juggling and plate
spinning but most of these shows they
didn't do well because people had seen
these acts before he realized that he'd
gotten very lucky with having joy
surfaces very first attraction people
wanted to pay for something they had
never seen before but he had a difficult
time figuring out what to look for
without having any experience in the
entertainment industry when he was 26 e
temporary
left behind his wife and children to
join a traveling circus in order to
educate himself on everything that he
needed to know about show business the
owner of the circus was a man named
Aaron Talon Aaron's Barnum told him that
he was eager to learn more about the
business
Turner decided to give him first-hand
experience with getting a crowds
attention the day before their opening
show Turner pointed at PT Barnum when he
was standing in front of a crowd
claiming that Barnum was Reverend
Ephraim Avery who was well known in the
newspapers for the acquitted of murder
everyone knew that Avery was truly
guilty and they were all talking about
him how many people actually knew what
he looked like but they all passionately
hated this man of course people believed
Turner's clayman's they began chasing
after Barnum who started running away
the angry mob it got bigger and bigger
and they weren't ready to take justice
into their own hands by lynching the
murderer at the last moment Aaron Turner
shouted that they were circus performers
and that it was all a practical joke
even though this could have been seen as
bad publicity it actually worked
everyone in the town was talking about
the angry mob and wanted to know what
kind of crazy men would pull such
dangerous jokes on each other
they bought tickets to the show the very
next day after six months with the
circus Barnum started his own small
troupe of traveling performers called
Barnum's Grande scientific and musical
theater he even bought a steamboat to
give tours and musical performances
along the river in the south but after
about a year of living on the road he
became very homesick he missed his wife
and his children and he wanted stability
he returns in New York hoping to find a
way to display curiosities and
performances without traveling from
place to place
[Music]
in 1841 Barnum purchased the Scudders
American Museum and transformed it to be
a much more appealing place to visit
he added flags to the outside and
created an elaborate rooftop garden
where a hot-air balloon
gave people rides on a daily basis
inside he had a menagerie of exotic
animals magicians and miniaturized
recreations of famous battles PT Barnum
was a genius when it came to getting
more people to come to his attractions
when the American Museum first opened he
wasn't selling as many tickets as he
hoped so he found an unemployed man and
paid him to run through a cycle of
various movements he would pick up a
brick on the street carry it to the door
show his ticket to the museum and walk
inside then he would walk back out again
place the brick back down pick up
another and continue to do this every
single day to the point where people
noticed this ritual on their way to and
from work some would even stop to watch
the man and ask what he was doing it was
enough to get people curious enough to
buy a ticket for themselves so they
could see what was going on inside as
time went on Barnum used the money he
made from ticket sales to improve the
quality of his displays he added one of
his most famous hoaxes the Fiji mermaid
he claims that it was the body of a
mermaid that had been caught off the
coast of Fiji but it was really actually
the skeleton of a monkey sewn on to a
fish tail one of his most popular live
exhibits was known as the freakshow
while some people disapprove of the fact
that he exploited people with physical
abnormalities like bearded ladies and
people with extra limbs he was giving
many of these people work when they
would have otherwise never found a job
he also paid his employees very well and
they were all treated like members of
the family every single one of the
members of the so called freak shows
became incredibly rich and all they had
to do was stand on display some of them
chose to retire after just a few years
of working and they went on to get
married and have very normal lives
when Barnum was 33 years old had been
running his American Museum for a few
years and it found some success but he
was always looking for the next big
thing he met Charles Stratton who was
one of his distant
Charles was only four years old and they
met he was a proportionate dwarf
standing only 25 inches tall he would
stay the size of a baby for the rest of
his life Charles's father was a
carpenter so their family did not have a
lot of money they were afraid for their
sons future because not many dwarves
could find work outside of the
entertainment industry and they were
never the star of the show anyway they
were always just on the sidelines used
as the butt of a joke
PT Barnum agreed to be his cousin's
manager and spent months teaching him
how to sing dance and act he was not
sure how well the audiences would enjoy
the show so at first he paid the boy's
parents $3.00 a week which is the
modern-day equivalent of about $70 his
parents agreed and they were just happy
that their young son could earn any
money at all
PT Barnum's strategy with Charles's
performance was to make him the polar
opposite of what people expected from a
dwarf
he gave the boy the stage name of Tom
Thumb
after the well-loved English fairy tale
he also claims that he was already 10
years old instead of five which made his
small stature even more incredible
thankfully Charles was a very smart
child and he picked up on how to talk
with the bigger vocabulary of a
ten-year-old rather than a five-year-old
Barnum advertised Tom Thumb as a tiny
gentleman dressing him in tailor-made
suits he was able to memorise
complicated lines and performed roles of
dignified figures in history like
Napoleon Bonaparte it worked a treat he
traveled all over the United States and
Europe becoming one of the world's first
international celebrities even queen
victoria was a fan of little tom famine
as time went on PT Barnum hired other
proportion of dwarves to join his
American Museum and this is where
Charles Stratton met his future wife
Lavinia Warren Barnum threw them a
wedding ceremony if it became front-page
news
presidents Abraham Lincoln was also a
huge fan and threw them a honeymoon
party at the White House
Stratton made so much money through
performing he could have retired at a
very young age but he genuinely enjoyed
it and he continued until he died at the
age of 45 the museum became so popular
that people would buy one ticket and
stay there all day even if they got to
the end of the tour it would get so
crowded the Barnum had to figure out a
way to trick people in
leaving he put up a sign that said this
way to the egress people assumed this
was a way to another attraction but the
egress is just a fancy word for access
once they left the building they could
no longer open the door and if they
wanted to come back inside they needed
to stand in line and buy another ticket
after having so much success with his
American Museum Barnum was able to build
a massive Palace in Connecticut for his
family to live he called the home in
rana stan because of its middle-eastern
inspiration he modeled the building
after the bright and royal pavillion in
england which was the summer home of
George Prince of Wales he was able to
host events and bring in famous guests
from around the worlds like the author
Mark Twain he used the large halls for
musical performances he believed that by
building such a huge castle famous
musicians would be more likely to
perform at his venues and it absolutely
worked in 1850 PT Barnum riders like at
finding musical talent from overseas he
convinced eight Swedish opera singer
named Jenny Lind to come to New York to
perform according to his autobiography
Jenny Linds only agreed to travel to the
United States because she saw the
engraving of araas tan on the
invitation letter and she wanted to
visit this intriguing Palace he had
never heard her sing but he learned of
her reputation when visiting Europe
Barnum was taking a huge risk by hiring
Jenny Lind especially since he had no
experience in the music industry even
Pater in advance to travel to the US but
Barnum used his marketing genius to hype
up her arrival so much that Americans
believed she was one of the greatest
singers in the world and that they would
be foolish to miss her limited time
performance he created posters that
dubbed her the Swedish nightingale her
first performance was held in the castle
garden and tickets sold out the shows
were so popular Jenny Lind performed
with Barnum 93 times over the course of
five months this newfound fame gave her
enough momentum to hire a new manager
and go on a world tour Barnum was taking
a cut of the ticket sales Jenny Linds
and 350,000 dollars while she was
working with Barnum for those
few months and she went on to make even
more during her tour Barnum received
$500,000 which is the modern-day
equivalent of nearly fifteen million
dollars tragically in 1857 men who were
hired to do repairs on irans tan while
Barnum was away in New York left a pipe
burning when they left for the day and
it caused a fire that destroyed
everything his insurance policy was only
paid out to $28,000 even though it cost
over a hundred and fifty thousand to
build the mansion and then in 1865 the
American Museum burned down as well he
rebuilt the museum but after only being
open for a couple of years that burned
down for a second time Barnum said the
fires burned to the ground all of his
life's accomplishments 60 years old PT
Barnum's life was a roller coaster of
success and failure he was at an age
when most men would decide to cut their
losses and just retire but one of the
many things that made PT Barnum such a
success was that he didn't let his
failures stop him from moving forward
his children all grown up and his wife
charity had sadly passed away he decided
that the time was right in his life to
start a traveling circus he was the very
first circus owner to buy his own train
to move the performers and equipment
from place to place he paid his work as
well and he made sure to use bright
colorful elaborate tents and equipment
which would attract crowds his first
traveling show was called PT Barnum's
grand traveling museum menagerie caravan
and Hippodrome this had many of the same
attractions he once had in his American
Museum only on much grander scale people
outside of New York City were able to
see his freakshow his animal menagerie
and his impressive acrobats that he had
collected over the years of networking
and making friends in show business in
1881 when he was 71 years old he joined
up with another circus which was owned
by James Bailey and their combined acts
became the famous Barnum & Bailey
greatest show on earth they were the
first 3-ring circus meaning that they
would have a three different acts going
on at the same time one of his biggest
attractions at the Barnum & Bailey
Circus was jumbo the elephant
he was one of the most popular animals
for children in London and kids in
America and they felt the same way
everyone was mesmerised by the massive
scale of this circus and they only
continued to improve upon the show as
time went on the Barnum and Bailey
Circus continued to tour long after his
death ending in 2017 it went on for a
hundred and forty six years as he grew
older fewer and fewer people criticized
PT Barnum for the tricks that he played
on audiences and more people recognized
the impacts that he made on the
entertainment industry he was well
respected by just about everybody here
at four books in his later years
including one called the art of money
getting in another book humbugs of the
world he was very candid about psychics
and magicians tricks and even called out
Harry Houdini he knew all the tricks of
the trade and wrote that he would pay
$500 to any medium who could truly
convince him that they were actually
talking to the dead his point was that
even though we know that magic and
ghosts are not real that doesn't mean we
can't enjoy the spectacle very few
people know the PT Barnum took politics
very seriously especially in his later
years in his autobiography he wrote that
a man who takes no interest in politics
is unfit to live in a land where the
government rests in the hands of the
people in 1865 US Congress would be
voting on the amendment of the
Constitution to outlaw slavery
technically he has once been a slave
owner himself with Joice Heth but he now
worked with and loved so many African
American performers that he felt
passionately about fighting for their
freedom and he used his money and
connections to join the Republican Party
as part of the Connecticut legislature
he wanted to do everything within his
power to help end slavery in the United
States and they succeeded the time he
spent on the Connecticut legislature
wasn't the end of his political career
though in 1875 he became the mayor of
Bridgeport Connecticut and he served for
one year and he was getting older PT
Barnum paid a reporter from the local
newspaper to write a very flattering
eulogy so that he could hear and enjoy
it while he was still alive he died in
a stroke of 79 years old he loved his
job so much that he was working up until
the day he died and his last words were
a request to look over some receipts two
years after his death a statue was built
in Seaside Park in Bridgeport
Connecticut on land that he had donated
to the city today his legacy still lives
on in the minds and hearts of everyone
who remembers the circus and his work
has influenced Entertainment as we know
it throughout the world
so really hope you enjoyed that video if
you did please do subscribe to this
channel we got brand new biographic
videos like this all the time that's
what this channels for that's what we do
also check out some other ones linked to
on the screen now and as always thank
you for watching
[Music]